[Musique]
les essentiels du Sénat
décarbonez le secteur des transports
en France le secteur des transports et
le premier contributeur aux émissions de
gaz à effet de serre avec 30% des
émissions nationales en 2021 alors que
la décarbonation du secteur des
transports apparaît comme un enjeu
majeur pour atteindre la neutralité
climatique à l'horizon 2050 la mission
d'information sur le développement d'une
filière de biocarburant carburant
synthétique durable et hydrogène vert
formule 27 propositions stratégiques
articulées autour d'un triptyque impulsé
accompagné simplifié dans son rapport le
sénateur Vincent capo canelas préconise
de soutenir les investissements d'avenir
et de développer une approche globale
il s'agit de mettre en oeuvre certaines
mesures défendues par le Sénat en
matière d'accroissement de la production
d'électricité des carbonée et
singulièrement nucléaire d'accélération
du raccordement au réseau électrique et
de mobilisation du foncier la mission
qui défend une stratégie de pilotage
global des enjeux souhaite que soit
étendu explicitement au biocarburant et
au carburant de synthèse le champ de la
future loi quinquennale sur l'énergie et
le climat
parallèlement la mission recommande de
faire des choix d'accompagnement
industriels économiques et sociales
dans cette optique le rapport souligne
l'importance de soutenir la recherche
développement et l'investissement
innovant il suggère de prévoir des
dispositifs d'accompagnement des
filières en transition et de mettre en
place une politique innovante de
formation et d'adaptation des métiers
pour répondre aux nouveaux besoins des
filières
le rapport recommande par ailleurs de
donner davantage de lisibilité aux
politiques de soutien national et
européenne et plaid pour un cadre fiscal
favorable au développement de la filière
des biocarburants selon les conclusions
de la mission en matière
d'accompagnement social certaines
filières nécessitent une transition
adaptée compte tenu de l'évolution des
prix des carburants aussi il convient de
veiller à ce que les aides publiques
viennent soutenir le déploiement de
l'offre française et européenne de
véhicules peu polluants le rapporteur
souligne en outre l'importance
d'accompagner les collectivités
territoriales notamment dans leur rôle
d'autorité organisatrice des mobilités
enfin la mission défend le déploiement
d'une stratégie offensive pour faire
face à la compétition mondiale en
matière de technologie verte
elle invite ainsi à renforcer la
vigilance sur les contournements dans la
réglementation européenne peut faire
l'objet en matière de biocarburant
avancé et propose l'instauration d'un
système de certification de production
durable de la biomasse au niveau
international
pour en savoir plus consultez le site
Internet du Sénat
[Musique]